wir schauen jetzt mal live in die
legendäre kampa die spd
wahlkampfzentrale in berlin zu birte
schneider
sie arbeitet neuerdings als
motivationstrainer für die leicht
verunsicherten genossen würde wie ist
denn die stimmung spitze die bestimmung
der spezi welke mit tendenz zu
fantastisch denn wir sind gelaufen wir
lassen uns nicht unterkriegen von der
vereisten war da oben in diesem von
höheren zugeparkten schleswig tings mehr
stehen immer wieder auf
man man man bisschen körperspannung
stehen
welche partei gerechtigkeit am erbe
meiner meinung am nächsten steuerung der
bürgerlichen vertraulich ganz genau auf
die leute und gelegene elemente kann
dass man versager es hat doch alles
keinen sinn die partei von august bebel
hat jedes selbstbewusster verloren
ihr kennt sie schon die neuen plakate
spd wir wissen es doch auch nicht
spd immer noch besser als eine eitrige
nebenhöhlenentzündung alles nicht wahr
sein sollte man sagen der schuld ist
werde wie welches als der deutsche
wähler die dummen
was sie eigentlich noch im märz top
umfragewerte für schuld und die spd
und jetzt auf einmal ich weiß nicht der
schulter ich glaube ich werde nochmal
die nach köln die kenne ich
vollidioten aber dann runter kommt dass
ich niemals alles in sechs anderen
schuld immer noch dieselbe klasse
benutzen und dann wegschmeißen
übungsfläche dass man nachts am
ballermann durch mut und dann nie wieder
anrufe wenn ihr den stolzen nicht mehr
wollen wissen sie wie ich in letzter
zeit gar nicht so schlecht findet
9 sigmar gabriel für dich sofort die
flasche was habe ich denn jetzt wieder
gesagt meine damen und herren
[Applaus]